I've enjoyed watching him in TJ back on
NFL primetime on ESPN plus or as I'm
calling it the plus it was the fastest
three minutes on a half-time last night
the old fastest three minutes from Chris
and TJ here's a little taste Ravens and
Texans supposed to be a showdown to the
big crab cake Lamar Jackson made a
mockery of that five Wooper I was
literally laughing out loud at home it's
just great to see good friend and I'll
thrilled to be able to call him a friend
in a longtime colleague Chris Berman
back here in the Rich Eisen show how you
doing Chris well Richard I can still
crack you up after these years and I've
done my job you know
that sound effect and nice to be with
you and Happy Holidays community we have
first of all it's just been a gas with
Tommy but honor with it with Lamar
Jackson
so woof was kind of invented for Barry
Sanders right right sure well he's not
that he's the first but this is Barry
Sanders like every week so we get to
bring out curly from the three from the
Three Stooges and make you laugh at home
that's what we're doing and it was great
I did literally laughter out a5 a5
looper and you know I'm wondering what
is what has it been like to be paired
with would TJ again Chris I imagine you
thought you probably wouldn't get to do
primetime again like like you did for
all those years well correct I mean if
we can't do it on over-the-air TV the
lost you know the deals the TV deals and
that's been that way as you know since
so fire but first of all Tommy is one of
my best friends in life let alone TV so
just to do the show a to do it with one
of your best buddies and I never thought
that would happen no I did suggest to
our new president who we like immensely
Jimmy Patera to look at the ESPN Plus is
a big directive here the the parent
company Disney and I think if we can get
the rights to
- primetime on that I consider coming
back a because it's fun B I think the
viewers or what do you call them on the
phone the the phoners I don't know and
Tommy was just unheard of bonus but I
also feel and I think you being an
old-time ESPN person will get this and
we started rich we had three million
subscribers well the phone or ESPN Plus
had like what in the twos when when this
one on in September and I said I think
we can move the bar and help you one
last time establish it so it was a win
on every count but to look the fans love
it it's the hundredth year football the
40th year of ESPN let's just aren't we
in the business to give people what they
want
I maybe not everybody loves me I mean
that's fine with that but here's
highlights and it's a hell of a show it
is can now access all the games but
really you're not I'd still think and
you do this sort of show I mean I still
think you want to sit down and have a
full meal okay I've seen the plays I've
seen this but I didn't see a Tampa in
Atlanta where they didn't play like you
don't I'm saying I didn't see that game
and give it to me in three minutes and
give me another one in three minutes and
and lo and behold it's 45 minutes rich
without any commercials which is you
think a mess to take a sip of water on a
live show but you have a commercial
break oh my god
but it's great Chris because again I
think in our current day and age those
who are in charge of sports television
products and distribution are assuming
people are seeing everything on their
phones whether it is through Twitter or
is through just being able to get a text
from somebody or they are watching it
live through some sort of streaming feed
that you've already gotten that
information and instead now all fans
want to know is analysis or argument
over who was right and who is wrong as
opposed to sitting
and getting a story told to them by
somebody who is expert at telling a
story and has fun doing it and at
conversation about what happened not
through the prism of X's and O's or
argument just two guys talking and I
can't get enough of it Chris I can't
well neither can we doing it it's a
blast it's something I would watch
whether we do it or not and look it's
for the fan it's for again to reiterate
and I've always thought that that
premise which you just laid out was not
wrong per se in some way but I do feel
every now and then you want to give me a
half hour give me 45 I give me an I give
me the full meal of especially in a
football Sunday give it to me
even if I've seen a lot of it but not
pieced together back to back to back and
it's just been that to go back to your
first question yeah it's it's
unbelievably fun but it's even better
than I thought it would be and probably
not speaking for Tommy may be better
than he thought it would be I mean it's
just his fine we watch the games we do
the show which was the best show that
I've ever done at least show you know
and we have to do it again and if I am
Bob Seger you know and not to compare
myself with a friend of mine but going
out on a final tour why wouldn't it be
NFL primetime it's it's a gift and I
hope it's helped the fans out there
think it's a gift and I'm glad you do
yeah I sure do it's on again on ESPN
Plus and it's on Sunday nights but it's
also available via replay through
Wednesday of every week so if you missed
it this Sunday you can go to ESPN plus
and and get it right now as I went to
break Chris I mean the the wagons
circling is working right now I mean
they're I think they're for real I don't
know if a lot of people would agree the
kid at quarterback can make some plays
with his arm and his legs John Brown is
putting together a season that only
people who own them in fantasy leagues I
think are paying attention to how viable
do you think these bills are Chris well
I think in that the big picture rich and
if you look at every team starting with
New England we're not going to analyze
the whole
because it's but everybody has some
flaws well I mean which is true all the
time but above all it's got a really
nice defense and I think that we started
to see the turn not that if you score
twenty you win all the games anymore but
we don't have a year like last year rich
ladies 54-51 right the Rams are the
Chiefs right 43 to 48 or you know 45 42
it will have some of those but the Super
Bowl was kind of the kickoff of you know
bring your defense that that may count
for a little more the next year and I
think we've seen a lot of that this year
so on that premise Bravo has a really
nice defense
do they have Bruce Smith the defense
event no but they they have a really
good team defense which is Shaun
McDermott's Forte anyway at Leslie
pressure so can they score in the 20s
that's the question for Buffalo because
you know they held they lost a game in
which they gave up 19 they got sixteen
two weeks to go to Cleveland so can they
score in the 20s if so then they're
definitely viable because as you know
defense is portable and you know they're
not going to win the division they could
but so they'll be on the road for every
game they play if they're lucky enough
to make the playoffs and defense is
portable bad weather it works so in that
way yes and if you look at okay so New
England and baltimore their head and
shoulders above everybody at the moment
you know will the Chiefs short things
out so if you look at just those two
teams if Buffalo bring in a defense yeah
they can make some noise yes I believe
that yeah I know and it looks like they
may have to go they could wind up say in
Indianapolis or Houston for for a
wildcard weekend playoff contest or even
Tennessee and that that one isn't out of
the realm for for Buffalo to actually
win a playoff game for the first time in
forever and then you know one of your
adopted NFC teams for the 49ers
they bring in their defense - I mean
what do you who is the best team in the
NFC based on what you can tell Chris
Berman through 11 weeks that's a very
good question NFC was first of all rich
isn't it nice and in the year they bring
back NFL primetime we get the 49ers in
the bills playing football best team as
we [ __ ] now I might leave to New Orleans
I know the 49ers only have one loss I
get it and that'll be a huge game down
there in a couple weeks only because of
the balance and we're looking at what
610 we were looking at San Francisco
Seattle and the Rams in the West we're
looking to Green Bay Minnesota a little
bit at New Orleans that's six and then
pick a team in the let's just say seven
who's the best balanced I I lean to New
Orleans now drew doesn't look quite
right yet some I get it but every team
kind of lost the game two weeks ago and
they all came back and won so to answer
your question best balance New Orleans
put here's Aaron Rodgers here's that San
Francisco defense here's Russell Wilson
who I picked before the year to be the
MVP and we'll see so what do you think I
mean I and that's a tight you know a
couple weeks ago would look like
Minnesota might have the best balance
although they don't have I like the
quarterback I mean but Aaron Rodgers and
Russell Wilson are you know a different
breed as is Drew Brees it is P I am I am
I am agreeing with you because I still
in terms of balance and in terms of
experience and in terms of being able to
put points on the board and in being
able to take away what a team can do
with takeaways that the Saints still
still add up they still add up to all of
that you know what I'm saying I mean
they still add up when it comes down to
it you know who will be able to
consistently do it who can do it in your
house whose house would be tough for you
to win in and then I do I'd still just
buy into football God's stuff whether it
is
you know as you pointed out you know
your your two favorite teams or did
opted teams are playing well when when
your show is put back on the air on ESPN
Plus just everything the fact that the
Saints won it all in Miami it's ten
years later I just I just I don't know I
put it all together and I still think
that the Saints despite that slip-up a
clunker happens every now and then I'm
just gonna say that's an outlier and see
what the Saints look like for the next
six and if you go the football gods
theory which you know you could go broke
predicting um their old one right I'm
not saying that that's why they would
then advance to the Super Bowl but
that's another thing that certainly
lines up we mean we don't have to rehash
January well it's also the year before
to that miracle that Minnesota pulled
off I mean back-to-back years for the
Saints to be knocked out and those
gutting fashions I hear you have Chris
Berman here on the Rich Eisen show so
the NFL 100 all-time team show is on
Friday night on NFL Network I am no I
voted on it and that's a year and a half
ago so and I don't know we taped it in
May and Belichick is dynamite Chris I
mean he is so good at being the analyst
for this show along with Collinsworth he
is so very good it's gonna blow a lot of
people away well let me just aside and I
know Bill pretty well and every time
through the years we get into a
discussion about not so what are you
gonna do a left tackle but so let's talk
about well for example this is years ago
now when he passed Curly Lambeau mm-hmm
I did a lot of homework on Curly Lambeau
I mean we know who he is and but you
know other you do some reading some
articles from this event and he knew all
about it not because he was passing him
just because he said he loves the
history of the game now in this on this
committee and Bill probably told you
this when he taped the show maybe you
didn't so he went back and looked at
film though guys in the 30s in the 40s
and linemen in the 30s and the
well Bill Belichick is going to look and
this is where all our 26 or 27 or 28
person panel we're listening to you know
I went back and look at Mel hime since
then XYZ for two minutes whoa you know I
wasn't that impressed when I first
looked at Bronko Nagurski but the more I
looked at my two questions he went back
to looking back on the crusties no and I
will say this and I pride
I called him privately before I made my
final vote not checking I hadn't decided
but I wanted to run a few of the
borderline borderline for example in our
final ballot we had to pick ten
quarterbacks do you know the guy I'm not
mentioning them do you know the guys you
have to cut cut to make only ten
quarterbacks we had tens a lot no it's
not a lot exactly because the first
seven or eight in almost every position
are obvious we're not ranking in order
so back to Bill I ran a lot of the
positions by I didn't tell him who I was
leaning like same three names sometimes
I have one spot give me what you say he
had someone everybody whether they were
yeah for the 40s or the 50s are more
likely 70s or 80s who early in his
career he was an assistant and coached
against well and there's awful it's he
brings that to the broadcast to Chris
for the players of that era 30s and 40s
who make the team because there are that
though that do make the team we we let
or the NFL Films people obviously we're
producing it had Belichick run through
those guys he was the one who talked
about those guys through the bela
straighter is what it's called where he
does the coaches clicker with whatever
grainy film they could on earth for some
of these players and the things that he
would say for these guys we were all
blown away the same thing as you were
like whoa we had the same reaction to on
the set and
the the reverence that he would have
safe for the old Baltimore Colts because
you know he grew up watching those guys
the way that he would talk about them
with a certain a certain excitement
which is the only word to put it for him
and it was great and here's one of my
favorite stories that he would tell
about I can't reveal which guy but there
was a guy who does make the team at
quarterback and he talked about how he
was at a camp and this quarterback was
there and he goes well I didn't catch
passes from the quarterback I was the
center for my team so I snapped him the
ball and I said the Collinsworth I'm
like is that the most Belichick thing
that he could have possibly said right
there you can't talk enough football
with them on because as you know cuz you
doing a wonderful job at that banquet
every year at the Hall of Fame and I've
been fortunate enough to be the emcee oh
yeah all these years but that's not the
point the point is he would I'd often
see him in August you know a training
camp or something after the Hall of Fame
awards and he'd want to hear stories of
guys I might have run into you know were
there saluting their teammates or
whatever and he couldn't listen enough
he's he's just he's all about football
and so respects the history of the game
and and I will say this and wanted I
mean I'll say this I'll say the player
because I'm not saying well who'll vote
I didn't ask him who he voted for you
didn't ask being liable for one name I
brought up with Fran Tarkenton why
things get completely overlooked at
forty-seven thousand yards yeah but he
no no no no he had the most yards at the
time treasurer bill
Fran Tarkenton lowers is on the phone
lowers his voice oh boy remember a
couple years I was in Detroit toward the
end of his run with the Vikings lowered
his voice even more Ballmer he was a
problem he was a problem and okay I even
need any analysis right I know I mean
when he you know he I mean he
coordinated against some he coached
against some he grew up watching some I
mean his
dad was a coach of the first variety in
the mid-atlantic area he was exposed
I mean he's perfect for this I can't
wait for you to see this no I'm excited
I was honored to be a part of it and and
you must have a gasps doing and I we
I'll just throw it and I'm sure these
two guys aren't on it so I just look
it's not for me to but I'm a historian
you know I'm a history major in American
history I mean let along with the
football and but most of the guys on the
panel forgot more football and then I'll
ever know I mean you know the list of
who was on there hello
you know the Belichick Don Shula John
Madden ooh Tony Dungy I mean we go on
and on right Ozzie and Dan Fouts and I'm
leaving tons of people out Bill Polian
Ernie Accorsi and what am i doing it was
more like how did I get in here but at
any rate I gave a speech for Jim Thorpe
and Red Grange okay and Jim Thorpe I
know didn't even make the final ballot
because I know what the final ballot but
I said look I'm just saying that it's
like voting for the MVP a little bit for
me just a few without those two guys
we're not having this meeting so I'm
voting for both of them now did I leave
out one or two oh my god you left out
X&Y yeah did I feel good about it no I
felt Jim Thorpe and Red Grange should be
representative for calling a hundred
players now but that's my interpretation
if it's not who ran for the most yards
you know that's a stat mm-hmm so it was
fun and parenthetically we're having a
show on Christmas Eve maybe you're
seeing on a Monday night I done my top
50 plays and well the light leaned and
something like last night we had a bunch
of Jim Brown Ron it's like you can't TV
makes it a little different than here's
a list right rich I mean it this is
different special but we'll put them all
together on a show on Christmas Eve on
top fifty that are being released three
at a time on Monday night countdown so
that'll be maybe under everybody's tree
same thing is fun with the hundredth
anniversary look we love pro football
and it's time to salute maybe even
educate those that
so were never hardly even heard of Gale
Sayers I'm not even talking about you
know Red Grange or Sammy Baugh or John
Hudson you know Gale Sayers to Isis whoa
to anybody under you know under 45 or 50
you know and it's fun too it's fun to
see that stuff and educate Chris you're
the man thanks again appreciate it great
the fastest three minutes loved it
NFL primetime loving it Sunday nights
exclusively on ESPN plus with Tom
Jackson TJ available via replay through
Wednesday each week Christmas Eve top 50
NFL plays as part of Chris Berman's
extraordinary contribution along with
the NFL 100 team to the NFL 100 campaign
I appreciate you appearing on the rich
Betty Davis Eisen show kim carnes will
sing the national anthem in just a
moment nice to be with you best of the
fam and same you guys the work you're
doing I can't wait to watch that show
you're means a lot take care Chris we'll
chat City about you got that's Chris
Berman everybody for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app